les partis mais tout le monde pas mal
comme toi six mois s'il n'a fait
beaucoup de bruit comme si rien ne
change à 10 hors colas moi j'ai pas
goûté garder le vous aussi c'est mon
mari non moi c'est ma copine avant non
mais c'est un sancerre vous savez
écouter alain près de son appartement
pour 15 jours pendant que les partis en
vacances
bon moi j'arrive qu'est ce que je trouve
rien non elle m'avait même pas laissé
son mari
non mais vous parlez oui heureusement
que moi dans les escaliers je vais
rencontrer un barbu marie aussi et barbu
elle était super je ne connaissais même
pas enfin je veux dire
une demi-heure avant je ne connaissais
pas mais il meurt après ses
connaissances et pendant quinze jours on
a fait connaissance du temps c'est rien
mais alors ma copine et se plaint alors
que qui sait qu'il m'a gardé sa place au
chaud dans son lit pendant quinze jours
c'est moi non plus mardi au guidon c'est
pour nous mais nous savons d mais c'est
quoi que ce soi disant que la baignoire
c'est pas un cendrier que les rideaux ça
sert pas qu'à se moucher que
j'avais pas apporté son au vison au
cloud alors comme moi il me restait plus
un radis
alors comment j'ai lâché des nouilles en
bas revenus aux bas oui mais je ne
comprends très bien mais vous savez les
gens c'est incroyable comme quoi
l'amitié
moi je vois 15 ans de mariage les mêmes
problèmes je pars qu'un jeu oui c'est
pour beaucoup non ça fait deux semaines
bon je vote et j'annonce à mon mari que
maman n'est pas morte
donc pas d'héritage il sévit dans une
colère au responsable et alors quand je
lui dis que moment aller mieux
c'était pire en pire a lancé ce que
c'est une parole amène aux paroles
camino de parole comme une autre parole
tout ça fait un gros mot alors cet homme
là est devenue rouge de colère c'était
épouvantable
alors quand je lis que maman lévirat
maison convalescence et en automne
c'était terminé
et voilà et voilà et voilà mais c'est un
amour ma mort c'est en leur faveur mais
c'est invraisemblable savait marquer je
le comprends cet homme là non c'est vrai
s'ils s'attendent à son héritage et
belhadj est déçus il n'y a rien de pire
que les espoirs déçus vraiment attendant
qu'est ce que je vais faire je connais
pas vivre sans payer mais pas le jour
nokia aux commerçants s'arrête en panne
avec le monde qui va et qui vient el
massa l'espère vous devez pas être
content tu vois je me sentirai jamais
chez moi mais non
ben je sais pas pour vous proposer parce
que moi je pars acapulco avec mon barbu
tout à l'heure avant ils attendaient une
rentrée d'argent qui m'a dit que décrit
récupérer le fric et monaco mais j'y
pense des voix vous allez tu es allé
dans son appartement
on n'est pas là orvoine ont beau simon
22 vous le pratiquez vous dira s
installe chez sorbonne
mon passage chez des copines de ben ali
au massif des copies de vallorbe
la vie de votre barbu est la salle à la
cette porte plainte pourquoi êtes vous
là
cette forte là c'est la porte je suis
sorti un peu ça moi je sais pas ce que
vous savez pas mais moi je sais je sais
pas acapulco l'héritage ma mère tout ça
c'est moi c'est mon mari ces boîtes mari
si votre mari mais c'est mon voisin vous
mettez votre voisin mais c'est mon mari
mais c'est votre voisin mais c'est quand
même mon mari elle est bonne celle là je
vous proposerai un appartement pendant
qu'on est parti avec un peu en dessous
serait chez vous chez vous alors qu'est
ce que vous voulez plus
ap ap alors c'est la meilleure celle là
un an passé la meilleure foule alors
match par deux semaines pendant 15 jours
pour faire mourir ma mère j'ai rencontré
une [ __ ] de palier qui prouveront
maria kaboul tandis qu'est ce que ça
veut dire d'un enfant soit la femme
arabe et services aux gens prennent trop
d'appartements dans la nasse envoie la
sphère en soit vous allez me
heureusement tout est à nord